all right uh by the way we'll be talking
to a lot of the candidates in just a
moment but first for more reaction we
bring in the host of the Ingram angle
wow the band is back together the one
and only Laura Ingram you know you know
you I was watching you with Bill hemmer
and Dana Perino and you said something
I've always believed that debates are
often about moments and I thought at
different times most of the candidates
had a moment tonight what did you think
I agree with you Sean like I think um
it's a starting sort of backwards I
think Nikki Haley was the best
establishment candidate you know she had
some zingers but I wasn't good enough to
kind of justify for them you know most
of the electorate a lot more money to
Ukraine probably not I think in the end
I mean Christie's always the best talker
he's probably the best debater up on
stage but it just actually connecting
with the Republican electorate it's
DeSantis and Vivek ramaswamy but after
the end of this whole debate did any of
them really you know make the case to
the American people that they're better
they would be better than Trump to win
the nomination I think that's a hard one
uh you know having moments that's one
thing but actually having a record to
run on and say I did this when I was
President the only one who comes closest
to santis and I think he got better as
the night went on he started off maybe a
little too Stern but as the night got on
not night went on I think he got better
and better so I think DeSantis and Vivek
and the pylon on Vivek ramaswamy with
with uh Nikki Haley and Chris Christie
governor DeSantis
he got better as it went on I thought
his opening answer was very powerful and
that is this is a nation in Decline and
that that to me kind of set the tone of
the night and that is okay all of most
of the people with the exception like
Chris Christie or ASA yeah most of the
guys on this stage would would point
this country in a totally different
Direction with I believe conservative
policies that would benefit every
American
right you're right Sean obviously this
is a Republican primary though right so
there are differences in the Republican
Party the old establishment more
represented by someone like a Mitch
McConnell obviously he's a very smart
Senator he's done a lot of great things
but is he the future of the party
probably not so I I think again Vivek
and and as a young guy and Ron DeSantis
as still young with an incredible record
as Governor those two men to me stood
out as as really the the potential
future the party is it enough to
overcome Trump I'm I'm kind of with uh
you know you know previous panel I think
that's going to be pretty that's going
to be pretty pretty tough maybe things
will change but uh again I think Vivek
coming out and and just taking on
everyone on that stage that's pretty
gutsy I mean maybe some people were
annoyed by it but I thought it was
pretty gutsy I enjoyed it I thought it
was a I thought it was a fantastic um
fantastic event tonight I thought it
added to the flavor of it for sure
thanks for putting on the tie for me
Sean good to see you
you're very welcome thanks for pointing
it out as usual hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else